hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the key
sets of ideas that is absolutely central
in Aristotle's metaphysics in fact he
says that metaphysics is in large part
concerned with understanding these are
what we call the four causes the idea
the reasons why something is or is the
way that it is and Aristotle's account
is quite interesting in that he does in
fact identify four main types of causes
that are distinct from each other that
in his view are not reducible to each
other and the same thing could be a
cause in multiple ways for multiple
things so the same thing could be for
example an efficient cause and also a
material cause but when we're talking
about one thing and its relation to
another it will be a cause for its
effect in one of these four ways
according to Aristotle and this is
really important because in his view
this is what allows us to understand the
why it is things are the way for those
things of the entire universe and it
allows us to even extend to thinking
about the the world as a whole or things
in general in the metaphysics he is not
introducing an idea that's totally new
for him because he references an earlier
work the physics and says the four
clauses are laid out there why is he
bringing up the this this notion then in
the metaphysics because metaphysics
deals with this and because in his view
all of the predecessors that he is
talking about from the Thal a s-- all
the way up to his teacher Plato and
everybody in between failed to recognize
the importance and distinctiveness of at
least one of these causes so they dealt
with them but sometimes in a less
explicit less articulate less
well-thought-out manner and some of them
may have only used one or two of these
causes to try to explain how things are
the way they are why they've come to be
the way they are Aristotle thinks that
this is the totality of the things that
can in fact be called causes in general
and this provides in his view a
comprehensive picture of causality so
let's take a look at each one of these
in turn and then think about how they
come together and we'll look at a few
examples that he gives as well either
from the physics or from other places in
the metaphysics so we have a thing we
have something that we want to
understand and one of the causes of the
thing what he identifies as the first
cause here first just in order not first
as in preceding all the other causes is
what we can call by convention the
formal cause now he doesn't actual
use the word form at this point in the
metaphysics he actually uses three other
Greek locations and we have translations
for them which we'll talk about in just
a moment one of these is Lucia this is a
difficult to translate term because it
doesn't always mean exactly the same
thing even in Aristotle he will
sometimes go back and forth and in what
he means by it but here you could
translate it as many people do as
essence as what makes that thing that
type of thing getting a little bit more
complex we have this interesting Greek
phrase that he uses more than once
Totti in a nigh and it's difficult to
translate this so you know some people
say well the essential nature but that's
not even close to what the Greek is
saying quite literally it's what it was
to be the aim is actually a past tense
and imperfect what the the the being
that it is or was so we're identifying
something that is central to it
something that is what makes that thing
that particular thing and then he's got
another locution tow deity idea means
through or by means of so that by which
something else or something is and we
can translate it as the reason why or
that through which you know any of those
sorts of things now you might say how do
you get from that to something that
would be a form or a structure well
later on in the metaphysics in the
section where he's actually talking
about causes he'll tell us that this can
also mean in addition to the Totti aana
and in addition to other things he says
it could be the whole the whole loan it
could also be the composition the
synthesis or it could also be
the form the a dose and we'll look at
examples of this that'll help us out in
just a moment
core relative to this we have the
material and here he says the second of
these causes is the in Greek cule which
originally means something like wood but
then comes to take a much broader
signification as matter in general the
stuff things are made of right and a
little bit later
he calls us the Hoople came and on which
we translate as subject or substrate
that which underlies that in which
things resign so let's look at these two
causes before going on to the other ones
and that will probably be been helpful
if we consider examples so we have this
piece of chalk and chalk itself is a
certain kind of matter a certain kind of
material a certain kind of who'll a
right and we know that it's some sort of
you know calcium limestone composite we
don't really need to know that as far as
Aristotle is concerned although it would
be nice to know what what precisely it's
made of and the chalk is a piece of
chalk has a certain form does it not
it's cylindrical I write on the board
with it because of its shape it was a
big chunk or something it would be less
wieldy for me to write on the board with
so it has a form or structure and it has
the material that it's made of this is a
thing likewise let's consider my tie my
tie is made of cloth and here it gets a
little bit more complicated because you
notice it's got different colors right
those different colors come from
different dyes different threads that
have been woven together in other
manners just pretend for a moment that
it's a single uniform gray tie so we
have gray cloth I'm not sure if this is
so this is 100
Silke so it's made from silk spun in
certain ways that's the material of it
and then the cloth itself is the
material is put into a certain structure
a certain shape that we call it hi could
have been used to make a handkerchief it
could have been used to make one of
those cloths I don't know if I I do yeah
I do in fact have it in my pocket that
we clean our glasses with let's say this
is made out of silk or something like
that right and this will you can ball up
in different ways than you can with this
again then the object it's got a
structure it's got a form that allows us
to identify it as that kind of object
and it's made out of something we can
get to quite complex types of organisms
right this binding and cloth and paper
and all of these marks and aerosol we'll
actually considers something like a word
a word is a certain form that's composed
of letters or syllables or however you
want to frame it so those are the first
two causes now Aristotle says that's not
enough to actually understand the
totality of the thing why it is the way
it is how it came to be and the other
two causes that he brings in he talks
about as opposed to each other or at
least set at opposite ends so the first
of these is what we call the efficient
cause and the efficient cause is what
brings that thing into being or produces
it or introduces that shape to it or
sets it in motion and he has a lot of
really interesting examples let's use
one that'll be particularly helpful that
brings in the formal and material cause
so if we think about
one of the instances that he brings up
over and over again the bronze statue we
have a statue it's made of the metal
bronze it has a certain shape that
allows you to identify it as a statue
and perhaps even this kind of statue
there were a lot of stereotypical
statues of you know gods or people doing
this or that so you look at and you're
like aha
that's a young man pouring water statue
made out of bronze how did that come to
be
there was some statue maker who produced
the statue the bronze worker and
Aristotle even goes a little bit further
he says how did the bronze worker do
that
did he just pop in there and start
subtly fabricating it no he had to have
a certain skill a certain art of bronze
working and that is also an efficient
cause of him in fact being an efficient
cause here we're getting a little bit
complex so let's actually drop that for
just a moment and it's enough to notice
that there's something that if we have a
form imposed on matter something that
could impose that form or produce it
Aristotle has another really interesting
example in the physics where he says
that the person who gave counsel is also
an efficient or moving cause and he he
calls this the honor hey taste Canisius
the source of the motion or change one
of the Aristotle's great contributions
to metaphysics in his view is noting
that there's another kind of cause and
he calls us a final cause this he labels
in a number of different ways he calls
it whoo Chanukah which we can translate
his purpose
literally on that on account of which or
that because of which or for which Tagum
the good or Telos the word we get
teleology from if you're familiar with
that term which means end or purpose or
and things in Aristotle's view have
final causes in fact he says that this
is one of the most important of the
causes because without a final cause the
efficient cause isn't going to do what
it's going to do and the final cause is
what you could say motivates all these
other causes and He will give lots of
examples of this we could think about
the statuary why does the person
actually make the statue may be their
final cause is to make a buck to feed
their family or it could be that they
really love making statues we could also
think of what why does the person
writing the words why do they set all
those down could be to communicate
knowledge and Aristotle thinks that
there are many things that are not
man-made or fabricated but are natural
and those have final causes as well the
final cause for some things could be to
continue their existence to produce new
versions of themselves to spread out and
take a portent role within an ecosystem
of course this is going beyond
Aristotle's views on the interrelations
between animals and plants but we could
well imagine that sort of thing now all
of these causes function together you
don't have them operating in a pure
vacuum like a final cause just by itself
sitting out there unconnected to all
these other things and efficient to
formal and a material cause likewise
material causes don't explain that much
on their own nor do formal causes nor do
efficient causes and Aristotle thinks
that metaphysics if it's going to do its
job well has to take account of and try
to understand all four of these within a
sort of Nexus
you